Hey, what's going on? It's bill burr
going on.
Ah,
um, it's, uh, what the
fuck is it? It's um,
it's time for the Thursday afternoon. Just
before Friday. Monday morning podcast.
Just checking in on you.
Ah, just checking in on you.
Just seen how your week's going. Huh?
Is it going the way you planned it?
Did you have any plants?
Think about that.
That's like some self
helps you think about that.
But like when you start
your workweek deep,
do you have a plan?
I mean other than getting in your
car, kissing your wife or, or, or, or,
or a husband or, or, or, or,
or, or, or a partner or, or, or,
or, or, or, or, or, or are, are,
are, are, are, are,
and you drive down the street and,
and an end and you get yourself a coffee
and you're going to work.
But,
but do you have a plan beyond just
taking the vessel that holds your saw
into that workplace?
Do you have a plan?
Cause I'll tell you right now,
God has planned,
God has a plan for you and you and
you and each and every one of you,
but you have to listen.
How can we know what our plan,
what
if we don't listen?
That right there is why I don't
go to church. The the, the use of,
of vocal dynamics they always get,
yeah.
Yeah.
And they come in for the whisper,
right? That's how it works.
It's called the Sandusky.
I'm sorry,
everyone from Penn state.
I know your teams ranked.
I know you're thinking you're going to
fucking somehow slip and slide your way
out of the horrors of that shower and
that no asshole sports fan like me is
going to bring it up. Oh No. It's
going to be brought up. Jesus Christ.
I'm going to take all the shit I took
for some fucking air pressure. You know,
you think you're going to take
down one God damn statute.
We all know you're going to put it back
up one of these days. We all know Joey.
Pause coming back up. Where
you gonna put it? Huh?
Were you going to put it?
Probably in the boosters room,
right when they bring all the money in,
they're all sitting there going,
it's okay Joe, you didn't know it.
We all know you never took a shower
and fucking 60 years. Why am I,
why am I doing this? I, you
know what, I don't know why.
Cause I've got a bunch of shit to do
today and that's the first thing that came
to my head. You know why? Because
God, God has a plan for me.
He has a plan for me to go on this
podcast each and every Thursday and just
checking on your week. That's my
mission. You what? I finished Westworld
and I have to rewatch the final episode
again because I didn't get it all right.
Granted I was fucking nod off like a big
headed drunk jackass on a cross country
flight, you know, head wakened me up.
I didn't quite get it. Um, but I know
there's going to be a season two,
so I would think there would be,
I gotta I gotta figure out what the
fuck happened. Uh, I'll watch it again.
But it was really hard to watch
it because my wife wasn't in,
she wasn't into this series. So she would,
every time I would watch an episode,
she would come in when the song was
coming on and she would just sing along.
She would sing like a,
a robot's focking people,
people dress like cowboys
something, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. Blue. What does it mean? Like,
I don't know, there's a certain, you know,
there's certain kinds of white
shit that Nia just can't watch.
And I found that it's like pre, I
don't know what it is. It's, there's a,
I think anything pre happy days, you
know, she's just like, yeah, this was not,
you know, it's like the
Louis CK bit. Like, you know,
these weren't the good old days for us.
So I think when she sees white dudes
walking around in cowboy hats, yeah,
she just does not get a good warm,
fuzzy feeling.
Sorry. If you could bend tune
in in late to the podcast,
you haven't turned tuned in lately.
Um, I, I have a touch of a bola,
but fortunately it's just quarantined
into my trope. You know what it is,
is I got this cough and then I smoked
a couple of cigars and then I came back
into a house where, you know,
whenever they say the job is finished,
it's not finished.
They have their punch list and that's a,
all this shit they need to do
and then the jobs fucking done.
So they keep kicking up dust
here. And um, anyways, so, oh,
Billy red velvet cake is,
um,
the last few weeks was
not working out because he
had this little bit of a cough and I am
exaggerating the cough before and you
guys are like, Jesus shaking my head,
fuck my life. Lol. You only live once,
um, all over my Twitter account. I, uh,
yeah,
I haven't been working out or anything,
so I just got on the little fucking
scale and I in the five I lost. I type,
I just put it right back on,
you know what I mean?
I'm really disappointed in myself. So, uh,
I did the half hour cardio this morning.
Do it with me. Here you go, everybody.
I'm doing a half hour cardio every day.
Every fucking day.
I'm getting on that fucking elliptical
and I'm going to try to lose two pounds a
week,
drop eight pounds,
get my fucking fat freckled ass down
to about a buck 75 sliding into the
fucking, you know why? Because God,
God wants you to be skinny.
He doesn't want you,
one of the seven deadly
sins is that spaghetti. Oh,
fatty motherfucker laying face down in
his bull shit from that movie seven.
Um, so anyway, so I've gotten back in,
I got my, I got the sports channels now.
So I've been watching my bro
ends. Is there a, you know,
get through this fucking season here,
trying to figure out what's gonna work?
What does it, um, we lost
it. The filthy floor.
You know what sucks? It was, I watched
the first two periods. It was too,
nothing flyers and a very subdued,
quiet fucking crowd.
Two would make me feel bad.
You know what I mean?
Usually the Bruins and flyers get
together. It's a rowdy fucking crowd,
I think because we're both fucking
transition. I don't, you know,
and you know what happened?
He looked at the standings.
Maybe the flyers are good this year. I
don't know. So I go out to the kitchen,
you know,
the brand new kitchen that's still is
the fucking punch lists to make myself
something to eat. And I swear to God it
felt like I was gone for five minutes.
I came back, it was two to two, right.
Marshawn scored. I forget who else.
And uh,
we went into overtime and then we lost it.
Sorry. No, we fucking lost it. So, and
I'm kind of keep my eye on the Celtics.
I know we got Sacramento next. Um, but uh,
you know what's so fucking dumb was
that complete non story of our center Al
Horford getting criticized
for four missing. Uh,
I think he missed a Miami
heat game because he,
cause you know he was with
his wife because she was
giving birth to his daughter.
Oh Jesus. Who has the fucking
nerve to call me during my podcast.
Don't you know God has a plan.
People,
when you walk away from your recorder,
always make sure you take off your
headphones. Cause if you don't,
you're going to yank that
fucker right across the Roman.
Then you're going to have all
that silence that you just heard.
Unless I took the time to edit it out,
which I probably will.
I'll probably do your solid and I
know what a lot of you millennials are
probably saying. Actually I don't
know what you're saying. You know,
you probably too busy having a fucking uh,
doing the mannequin challenge or
something else. Really important. Um,
why talk down to the youth bill?
Why would you do that? Huh?
Is it cause you're your everyday
creeping towards death? Um,
I know what you fucking
technological douchebags it probably,
why don't you just get some
wireless headphones? You know why?
Cause I think I got enough
satellites pointed at my
fucking head. How about that?
I've got enough signals going in there.
I can't remember shit.
I've had this cough for two weeks. He
know when I'm blaming wireless headphones.
You hear that echo in my office. That's
cause I cleaned the fucker up a Cli,
this fucker and I got
rid of a bunch of shit.
I organized a bunch of stuff.
I shredded a bunch of shit and I'm
feeling good about it. I know we're all,
my stuff is, I'm, I'm selling
the Prius and you're, it's funny,
I have the title to every God Damn
fucking car I've ever had except for one.
You know, my first one,
but I, I had an 88,
I had an 88 fucking a Honda accord
LX that I bought in like 1996,
five speed.
I fucking love that car.
And I had it for like four or
five years before I sold it.
When I moved back to New York. And,
uh, I found a copy of that title.
I found every fucking God damn title
that I needed except for the fucking,
the one for the car that I'm selling.
So now I had to send it away.
I got to send away for it, for
the, uh, to the fucking DMV.
So I got to do that bullshit today
and do it. I get to taste something.
It's laugh all you want
about the Toyota Prius,
say as much homophobic stuff as you
want at people who drive Toyota.
Paresis not only is that a great God
damn car, it's got great resale value.
People want that fucking car.
You know Tony,
that gas smells laugh all you want. Say
it looks like a doorstop. Say it's gay,
it's soulless. She got no balls. You know,
I don't understand people that
identify themselves with their car.
I understand liking cars. I
love cars. You know what I mean?
But I don't like look at something that
another man built an act like I had
something to do with it.
Like a lot of these other cons.
Now it's one thing if you fucking,
you know, you, you, you know whatever.
You go down to the God damn junkyard like
the gas monkey guys and your build it
from fucking scratch. Then you
can have some pride. All right?
But if you're that fucking huckleberry
that walks out of their lot and then buys
it for four to five grand more than
what you should have fucking paid for,
then you walk around leaning against it
as you drink an astrologer beer, right?
Standing there like you won a war.
I don't understand that aspect of it.
Which brings me back to the Toyota
Prius. All right. The Toyota Prius.
Like most of you, I did not
build that car. Oh right. So
why are you trying to put
that on to my personality?
You know it takes a strong
man to drive a Prius.
Nia.
Yeah,
you up?
What do you mean? How can you not be? You
are awake earlier when I talked to you.
Okay.
No, pull that shit. You already ruined
my day with all the jobs you have for me.
Can you please come up here
and sing your Westworld Song?
Okay,
can you do that? Boop, boop,
boop, boop, boop, booboo.
What are you so grumpy about?
The God damn door open.
You're screaming at the top of your lungs.
It's like, what are you doing to me?
What do you want? I'm making
money. What can you do a quieter?
Hey, let me hear the Oh, shut up. You've
already awake. That's your big complaint.
That's your big complaint in life. What
are you doing any other places? Well,
sit here. Well, are you moving
on my shit? Come on man. You
got to sing the song. What?
Are you pregnant or something?
Yeah,
I just came up the stairs and I'm
out of breath. Do you want from me?
I'd like a little sunshine today.
Do you want another microphone or
what you want to be on the podcast?
Yeah,
no, Jesus. I got to hit pause.
Liver. Catch your breath. All right.
What back? Hell, Nia.
I want you to show called Westworld.
Please don't flashed me. Huh?
I'm not flashing. Sorry.
I got my bathrobe.
Sorry.
Like Sharon Stone right now.
It's a good stay. Oh, there's the,
there's the Photoshop
for the fucking week.
You're on your red sox row with
nothing on underneath it. Yeah.
Can you have a little
consideration for the listeners?
They don't want to think about
that. Jesus Christ, they worked out.
I'm a fuck a guy. You know, you
take a shower, you put on a robe,
you have a couple of fucking eggs.
What I'm trying to do is I'm trying to
get all this shit done before you fucking
all the crap that you decided in your
head that I was doing today without
checking with my schedule.
Yeah, yeah, I did that.
Yes you did. Okay. All right.
Well no one the Westworld song.
Okay.
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo robots.
Fucking people.
People dressed as cowboys.
That's as far as I got fucking ruin the
whole song every time I went to go watch
it. Now let me ask you this, you kind of,
I noticed like there's certain types of
fucking white movies you don't like and
cowboys is one of them. Anytime the
cowboys you fucking tune out early.
I'm just not particularly interested
in certain areas of white history.
That's what I'm saying that I called that
earliest a certain things I'm just not
particularly interested in.
I talked to him.
You don't see a lot of black
cowboys in those movies. It's weird.
Where were the black people there that,
let's see.
Well it depends on when it
was. It was like the 1880s
you mean they had, you know,
did you guys have your own stage coaches
at that point? Oh yeah. Definitely.
Had our own stage air shocks on
him and shit on businesses. Yep.
I thought you did initially
and you started kicking the
shit out of white people
cause then it, then they
went, whoa, Whoa, Hey Z.
Hey z that happen right after slavery.
Now there wasn't then you guys,
a bunch of you got elected and
shit and then acted to what? Well,
cause you had numbers. Numbers for what?
What are you talking about right now?
I can't remember if this was a video
game, if this was actually okay.
No, like right after you guys got
free or your sense of history is just,
it's amazing.
I thought like you guys got
fried and then like you started
succeeding and then all the broke
ass white people around you lie. Why?
Why you don't man. And that's when
they came up with the Klan. Maybe.
Maybe too many of these Tarantino
movies where he fucks with history.
I don't know what's going
on, but I thought, I thought
you were doing it right.
None of this, none of this is
correct. I'm not a historian,
but I didn't the clumps do something
around then to the whole, the clumps.
Who are the clumps? Eddie Murphy and
fucking knows, oh, he's just being silly.
Silly. All right, whatever.
So Nia, what? What exactly are a that
that that song was a little disappointing,
but I don't really have much.
What was I saying?
I was like Anthony Hopkins playing God.
Yeah, you'd ruin the whole fee.
Every time I would go to watch it,
you'd stick your head in the room,
Jeffery. Right? They get
there and he knew them.
Hbo is a bunch of perverts.
They always have these shows.
Everybody's just fucking naked. Ahs.
Westworld, three kings, one of the,
fuck. Hey, we're all in the castle. Look
out for the Dragon. Game of Thrones,
game of Thrones, eight year old
king. Hey, we're, hey, we're all,
I don't get how an eight
year old guy again.
How does an eight year old king
fucking sentence someone to death.
I never watched you just said, what'd
you say? You Little Shit. I have no idea.
What tip you over in that giant fucking
chair. What are you gonna do about it?
A little evil fucker. Dude. That kid
needed the living shit kicked out of him.
Hmm.
Yeah,
I didn't watch a lot of episodes,
but if ever I could throw an eight
year old off a building or a castle,
definitely I'd want them to live to
this theories. I, I have no idea.
I saw one of them,
he pulled a guy's fucking tongue out
cause he didn't like the song he was
playing.
Yeah. There's like too much like
incest and dragons and shit.
I'm just that, that kind of genre. I'm
not really into, although I did love game.
No, not cancer. Um, uh, Lord of the
rings. That was an awesome movie.
But I don't know what the part of white
history does that take place. It doesn't,
it's make believe it's not real.
I like fan like some fantasy stuff,
but I don't like there's no middle earth.
I don't think so.
If middleware it had to vote,
which way would they go? Nia?
That's a good question.
I don't know.
You'd have to talk to some
like tolken nerds for that.
They might be able to tell you if they're
more liberal or conservative and this
fantasy in a nerds,
Chris Hardwick from the Nerdist,
he's doing a fucking game show that I'm
calling it right now is going to be the
biggest hit game show since.
Who wants to be a millionaire?
It's called the wall.
I don't know what it is,
but it's fucking broke ass people who
could possibly win 12 million bucks in the
fact that so many people are upside down
in their houses and the look of fucking
hope on these people's faces.
It's the APP
like
literally almost breaking down crying
like you never see that on the prices,
right? You don't see that
on the wheel of fortune.
You certainly don't see it on jeopardy,
but this wall thing,
they got these fucking people like,
like these people are so excited to win
the fucking prize in the trailer that
they're going to need some sort of
counseling if they lose, if they blow it.
Right. Do they ever do that
shit anymore on game shows?
Remember back in the day when you could
fucking bully people and tease him where
it's like, do you want to take
that money in my pocket now? I do,
I number tell them. And they'd be
like, and people always just like,
fuck you money for it.
Right then.
Then they'd will listen to the
crowd and there'd be 700 bucks,
which could buy you like a fucking,
you know,
I don't know why they probably buy a
mercury monarch back then or some shit and
nice down payment on one.
Anyways,
you'd put it back into the
guys Ron Burgundy sport coat
and then they would open
up the door and half the time it'd be
like a fucking donkey or a yak or some
shit. And they go dunk on
the tone back and do that on,
let's make a deal with Wayne
Brady or do they still do that?
Still have that show? Yeah, he's
the host of it. I've only, yeah,
but this is the thing. But they all
dress, they're all dressed up though.
So that takes the shame away from it
because you can hide in your costume back
in the day you stood there and you looked
like what you look like and then the
next day you were walking down the
street, you're like, oh my God,
you're that guy that could have fucking
one seven or eight minute, wait a minute.
I didn't.
I when we were in that,
that rental home with the Campbell that
only had an oldies television for some
strange reason,
I saw an episode of let's make a deal.
And there was a couple that was dressed
up as raggedy Ann and rack the, yeah, no,
no, absolutely. And it was like
in the 70s that show they did.
But I'm saying that was all,
there was all these other game shows
where people didn't dress up and there was
always the booby prize is what
they called it and it was not tiddy
alright, wanting something fucking nuts.
This is a complete non fucking story.
I started to talk about it. And then
of course they'll fucking went away.
And the God damn cables out,
not the cable,
the fucking Goddamn Internet,
like press the reset button on
the right, the router. So this,
this Guy Al Horford who
plays for the Celtics,
he used to play for the
Atlanta for the sellies.
He used to play for the Atlanta Hawks.
This year we were making a big, uh,
we want to try to get Kevin
Durant and then we couldn't.
So then evidently all the money that
we were going to give him to rant,
we gave three quarters of it to this
Guy Al Horford give him like 130 fucking
million dollars over four years
or something crazy like that. Um,
maybe a little less than that came
out to about 28 million years.
So listen to this shit. So this
fucking guy, his wife has a kid, right?
It has a daughter.
So he misses a game and some fans
bitched about it on like a social media.
And it actually became like a story he
thought out of game because he wanted to
go to his daughter's birthday party and
then a couple of Douche bags are like,
oh the fog to pay
you all the morning put ball Lou.
And then the media picked up
on it and then he actually,
he actually had the comment on Twitter
nerds and it was like one sports show
that brought it up are his priorities.
What are you going to do
in here if I don't show up?
You know if I'm at the Rose Bowl
hammered and you give birth or um,
we've already, this guy don't
even joke about it hammered.
We've already discussed the plan for
the Rose Bowl. Can I tell you something?
Even if I walked into delivery
room blind drunk, you can't,
you're still going to be totally fine
because everybody doing all the heavy
lifting is there. Like I,
I shouldn't even be there.
I don't understand why you keep trying
to like evade any kind of like role of
being like my support and comfort
Mike. My emotional support. Yeah.
You don't even stand in the room
when I get my teeth cleaned.
That's a little bit different
than you think. Yeah.
What if they want removing a tooth?
Would you stand there and hold my
fucking hand? No. For God damn sure.
That is not the same thing.
Why are you even bringing that up?
Because it's fucking bullshit
that the guy has to be in there.
And every guy I talked to, nine out
of 10 of them go, yeah, it's bullshit.
Just stay north to the fucking blanket.
And it keeps them happy.
You just weren't emotionally support me.
And when we went to the class the other
day and you watch the birthing story,
you leaned over to me and you were like,
oh, I understand now I understand why. No,
when he was walking with her,
went walking with her in the halls,
I understood that being in
there for the procedure,
I completely don't understand.
And I just think that that is one of
those things that it's just one of those
does that fucking hat thing
that you guys do and rub right.
Rub My back and be like,
you got this. You're good.
Just breathe like you're
okay. Yeah. All that kind of,
it's just like every time I walk out the
fucking door and I got all this shit to
do. You always throw a couple more
things. Hey, go get the dry cleaning.
Can you go do this? And he'd go do that
and yet you're dumping your fucking,
you'd taken the it off of your pile.
You take the dog to the vet actually.
Okay.
I'm not taking the dog to the vet.
You're taking the dog to the vet. Okay.
Yeah. I'm moving all that other
shit down there. [inaudible]
you're going to have some help.
You're not the only, I mean,
you know my brother is because you're
on the podcast that you're coming with
this,
this fucking arrogant tone I don't know,
is because of you're on the podcast
and you're coming at me with this extra
fucking Douchey vibe.
I always have this vibe.
Fair enough. Fair enough. Fair
enough. I got some ads to read.
Oh, did you think, um, oh
frame was it frame grab,
frame grab. Is that, is that
the right, is that the way to
sand?
No,
I knew who they were until you just said
is these people that advertise on our
podcast, they send us a couple of frame
things, whose stuff was very nice of them.
Oh, nice. What the fuck is their name?
Frame, Greeks. Frame. Frame used.
I can frame it versus framer.
What is it? Uh, I know where
I can go to figure out. Oh,
well you go figure it out. I'm going
to, I'm going to read some advertising.
All right. Oh Shit. Nia, look at, here's
the advertising. Give me the look.
I get a little bit thing.
I get a little biggie smalls on my desk,
a loot crate from thanks to Joe
Rogan. He hooked me up with that. Ah,
loot crate everybody.
Be The envy of your friends and
get a hundred percent exclusive
crates@lukecraig.com slash burr and
enter my code B U R R to save $3 Oh,
holy shit.
It's the price of a sloppy Joe
off on any new subscription.
Oh, frame bridge. I'm sorry. Frame Bridge
where the people that hooked us up.
Thank you very much. That's an
advertising within advertising. All right.
Waiting to near you. Gotta listen
to this stuff, Lou Craik. Okay.
Wait until I tell you about
December's crate. Nia.
You wait right in that doorframe it will
have you fighting the power. Oh Shit.
Is this blaxploitation um,
loot crate offers an epic range of pop
culture items for less than $20 a month.
If you are a more fanatical Fashionista,
Nia,
then try loot where?
Monthly wearables and accessories
with cult classics and your favorite
franchises.
Let's see if they're advertising towards
the African American community with
some of this shit.
If you want to get fancy,
get a bigger box with even
bigger load with Luke Craig DX.
Does that mean you're fatter? Oh,
that would be loot crate x XL, right?
Want to geek out your pet. Try
loot pets. Now Jesus Christ,
they try. They're trying to
cover too many bases here.
Offer expires December 19th at 9:00 PM.
Uh,
get ready for December's
rebellious theme revolution. Nia,
they're always watching. All
right, here we go. Let's see what,
let's see what they got here.
They've designed a system to keep
you down and their metals in there.
Ma Meddlesome hello friends.
It's time for the for revolution.
December's crate features exclusive
items from assassin's creed.
Anything near
Mr. Robot firefly.
All of the TV show and our monthly
tee shirt and pin and more including
exclusive Funko pop.
Oh Jesus.
That sounds like a bunch of
white dad's in a bad garage band.
We are a Funko pop a do not wait.
You have until the 19th at 9:00 PM
Pacific to subscribe for December's crate.
When it's over,
it's fucking oh no more crates.
Go to loot crate.com/burn
and enter my code bird.
Save $3 off on any new subscription.
Alright,
couple more of these. He looks
Hallux. You know what? Your unique,
let's start by pandering to you and your
fucking ego. You're unique. You know,
walk like everyone else.
Talk like everyone else or even
sleep like everyone else. Uh,
so why is your mattress one size fits all?
How do they know how the fuck you sleep?
They must be watching your three,
your smart television,
right?
Fucking Weirdos because it truly
customized mattress will cost you five to
10,000 bucks until now. Go to hell.
It's helix, sleep.com helux okay.
It's never been. It's
always helix. I want,
what do you know about it? I know
that it's not Elyx. All right?
He likes sleep.com.
Answer a few simple questions and they'll
run a three d biochemical model of
your body and then sell that to another
corporation for profit from prior shit.
Proprietary Algorithms that they've
developed with the help of the world's
leading era garments in biochem.
Dude,
they're fucking taken a whole thing of
your body so they can turn it into a
robot and that's your replacement.
Westworld.
And that fucking mattress is your coffin.
But
the result, the most comfortable
mattress you've ever slept on,
people's sleeping on mattresses,
robots replacing them.
Now helux helix fuck customers report
a 30% improvement in overall sleep
quality. How do you know you was
sleeping? Um, and from couples, oh,
Jesus. Now we're getting
funky. He'll Funko pops,
going to be playing on the
background on this one.
They customize each side of the mattress.
Your mattress arrives at your door and
about a week and shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from Gq magazine
to Forbes are all talking about helix
sleep. You have a hundred
nights to try it out, gross.
And if you don't love it, they'll
pick it up for free. Yeah,
with a fucking a hazmat suit on and give
you 100% refund, no questions asked.
Go to hell.
Heloc,
sleep.com/burr and get
$50 off your first order.
That's helix sleep.com/burr helix,
the cats,
sleep.com/bar oh I kinda liked the idea
of them doing a scan of both of us so he
can adjust the mattress for both of our
sizes. Really? That's a cool idea. No,
it isn't. Why isn't it a cool, they're
going to scan your body, right?
And then they're gonna get that lives
in this system and then somebody's going
to buy that. The scan your fucking body
and I'll make you a health insurance.
Go up and everyone's going
to know what size of jeans,
so people are going to call you
up. You know, he goes, fuck it.
Everybody calls her home phone. We
never answer our home phone. By the way,
every time you pick it up,
it's just a recording.
It's drop everything you're doing and
listen to this opportunity for your
business.
Do you wear a size 34 32 genes?
How do I know that?
Thanks to helix sleep.
All right, tracker.
Speaking of big brother,
we're all loses Newsweek reports.
The average American wastes 55 minutes
a day looking for things they own but
can't find. Not when you reorganize
your fucking office. Like I dunno,
I just pointed at you when I get that.
I know in a very acute chairs, Nia,
you can do this one. Share a story
when you lost something you needed.
Uh, what? Talk about the time
I broke up with you please. Um,
tracker makes losing
things a thing of the past.
And I'll tell you how to get one for free.
And a minute tracker is a coin size device
that fits to the base of your skull.
Um, trackers, coin size, device that
locates, misplace keys, wallets,
bags, computers, anything in second,
just pair of tracker to your smartphone,
attach it to anything and find his
precise location with the tap of a button.
It's that easy. I don't know why I
don't do this. Why don't I do this Neil?
Because you have this like thing with
technology that you just resist even when
it thank you.
Color the show going lose your phone,
press a button on tracker
and your phone rings.
Even when it's on silent
tracker is finding over 100
million over of our million
misplace items each day. Orders
Order Yours and never lose anything.
Again, listen, I'm gonna if I put
that one on one with my eyeballs,
why not lose my place when I read the
copy? I'm Jesus. Listen to this show.
Get a free tracker. Bravo. With any order,
go to the tracker.com and
enter Promo Code Burr.
The hardest thing you'll ever
have to do is find their website.
I'm going to tracker.com right now and
enter the Promo Code Burr for your free
tracker. Bravo with any order. Again,
hey, that's tracker.com Promo Code Burr.
And lastly, but not leastly.
Oh, it's Siki everybody.
It's SeatGeek.
Everything about seek is designed to
make life easier for sports and music
fence.
See does all the price comparisons for
you by searching multiple tickets sites
and ensuring that you get the
best possible deal. Let's see,
does all the work and you save
time and Munskey and seek,
wants to help you get the
most bang for your buck.
That's why every ticket on seek is
given a grade based on value your work.
Okay.
No walkie,
um,
you'll immediately see any
underpricing and if they suck,
I don't want you under price seats and
be able to find the best deals that fit
your budget. Best of all my listeners
and anybody else who reads this copy,
get a $20 rebate off their
first SeatGeek purchase.
Call to action must re don't
tell me what to do. Your con, uh,
to get your $20 rebate on tickets,
download the [inaudible] APP,
go to the settings tab and click on,
add a promo code.
Enter the Promo Code Burr seek equals
send you $20 after you've made your first
ticket purchase.
Download the SEATGEEK APP and enter
Promo Code Birth. All right, there we go.
What are we up to here? Oh, 33 minutes.
Well, I've fulfilled my obligation. Yeah,
I started off doing it.
I did a little bit of the church
this morning. Maybe cause I'm,
I'm wearing a robe with nothing
underneath it. I'm having this,
this Catholic Church Fun.
We're talking about.
What are you talking about? Um, neo.
Do you think God has a plan for you?
Because I'm here to tell you that he does.
I feel like an empty long time. You could
have been one of those TV evangelists.
I could literally do it as a joke and
just to see how far I get and then the
energy, everybody their money
back. But then they'd be mad at me.
I'm just fucking with you. I don't know
what you're going to go to hell or not.
Here's your money back and
just judging yet. Just kidding.
Remember when Jesus died and then he
came back? I just fucking with you.
That's what I was doing.
How's that cough, Dylan?
It's doing great with me. Yeah, good.
It's doing fine. I'm going to go
play drums after this by the way,
before you have me move half of
this fucking house. All right, well
all right. When, when, when, when his old,
when, when like what is my schedule today?
Can I put a tracker on my fucking,
uh,
like when did you have me moving all
of this shit coming over at noon.
He's kind of like, Eh, don't hit me
with your Calabasas fucking accent.
You haven't been out here long
enough for that shit. All right.
You make me so tired.
I'm hungry.
I had to make some Turkey bacon
and some eggs or something.
You make me so tired.
You make me tired. I'm already tired
and you're making me even more tired.
Weight tracker. How about
that? Uh, the little,
the little baby lojack. Did
you talk about that? Oh yeah,
we went to the hospital
yesterday cause they,
the hospital till they give you a
tour of the hospital near goes, hey,
let's take a tour of a couple of
hospitals to see where we want to fucking
deliver. So I'm like, all right, I'm
thinking we'll walk around. Yeah,
look at those nurses. They're pretty hot.
Let's go here. Right? We fucking show up.
We got to sit down in another
class in and she's like,
this is going to be 90 minutes
long. It's like, fuck me.
Fuck me 90 fucking minutes.
So we're sitting there and
she goes to finish first.
Let's go around the room
and introduce each other.
Say Your names and what you're having
and all that. So write down, I'm like,
this is going to be, by the end, I
loved her. I thought she was great.
But like I am, I, you know,
I'm a comedian. Yeah. I don't,
I don't do well in the group dynamic
at seen how bad I wanted to say.
My name was Russel. This lie. Yeah.
I wanted to lie and I just wanted
to lie about what we were having.
I just wanted to lie. One of the
lie through all of it's nothing,
you know folk and just show me where
she's going to fucking have it.
I sat there for 90 minutes people,
all I have to do is fucking pull up,
drop her off,
go to the fifth floor,
make a right and I dial
four numbers and I'm done.
And I had to sit there for 90 minutes.
One hour was her talking and then 30
minute, he's a great speaker though.
She was and she was adorable and she
was a great mom and I loved her and they
gave all the dads diaper bags at
the end, which was very, very cool.
I thought.
But the last day always talked to us
like we're dopes the last 30 minutes we
actually watched guys,
I mean you're going to be standing there
with your fucking head up your ass.
I'd so want to sit there and be like,
you realize men built this hospital and
all major medicine was because of men.
I'm just saying they took every fucking
thing when it comes to the male and
female dynamic, when they talk about
the guy, if there's a woman running it,
the shit that they say, they always
talk to us like we're fucking stupid.
The exact fucking thing that all these
broads who are feminists say they don't
want done to them.
It happens all the time to us all
the fucking time and look at you.
You could care less the same way.
I don't give a shit that you make a
dollar less than hour than I do to go down
to the Laverne and Shirley plant and
put little caps on those beer bottles.
Shimmy all shemozzle. What does that
mean in Yiddish? Oh, I don't know.
Is that, is it Yiddish? Yeah. I
love Yiddish. Shamil is a guy,
he's the kind of guy who goes out to
a restaurant. He spills some soup.
Sh schmozzle I think that's how you
say it. He's the guy he spills it on
under. That is right. It is right and
you want to both. You want to bet. Sure.
You want to know how much you want. In
fact, Bill Soup. I swear to God, Bro.
Some fucking clothes. I so I'm
standing up now. No, but that,
that robe just and not be
contained. Contain what? Uh,
how much you want to bet?
I don't know. 10 Bucks.
All right. All right.
Let's look it up right now.
We're talking about the baby lojack third
30 minutes of it as we walked around
the hospital. Oh yeah. They got
these little, these little fucking,
he showed us some newborns and
it was so cute. But they have a,
they have a security in place these
days for babies. I did not know.
They had a little ankle
bracelet on the thing like it,
like it was on house arrest just in
case somebody came into the hospital and
started stealing babies, which I've
never fucking heard of that ever. That.
It's slowly getting, you used to having
that thing now it's just on their ankle.
Oh, booed. You do boop, boop, boop.
And then eventually it's fucking in
them telling you to get off. That's all.
When the baby steps baby steps,
you baby step your way into something
that they have an id tag on one ankle and
then they have a little
cool
ankle bracelet on the other
to keep track of them.
Are you actually,
are you googling Shamiel schmozzle yeah.
I'm going to get one on one.
One of fucking 10 bucks.
Okay.
All right.
Seeing how wrong you are.
Oh God. I cannot wait to find the
fucking page because I looked it up.
You're awfully comfortable. I
mean, you're awfully confident,
so I'm starting to think whatever
money you want to fucking bet.
It's only 10 bucks. All right, here we go.
Shamil shemozzle office Bevin half ins,
Pfeffer incorporated.
Uh, uh, we're gonna do,
we're give his name.
Shamil schmozzle are to Yiddish
terms off to use and comical,
but sometimes biting
sense of humor. Uh, uh,
Shamiel is somebody who opt in,
spills his soup,
and a [inaudible] is the
person that lands on. Ah, wow.
I owe you $10.
Pay Up.
Fuck nee nee pay up.
Congratulations. Thank you.
That's $10. Tell you what,
you can keep that $10. It's worth
the fucking robe. It's closed.
Uh, you'd beat me to the punch. I
was going to say I'd give you a $10.
I'll be like, you keep your $10
and have to do those dumb ass jobs.
Um, all right, there you go. This
has been the full frontal podcasts.
Um, oh my God. Oh, stop it.
You so fucking dramatic.
It's just a God damn cough. I'm insight.
There's heat and I have aspirin.
I'm going to be fine. The bill burn
memorial podcasts would be Monday.
Oh. Speaking of that, speaking of
a, you know, I'm in my forties.
I have a lot of friends
that are no longer here.
I got a couple of benefits
to promote peak common. Um,
this Tuesday, great friend of mine
unfortunately passed away, uh,
uh, about a month ago and, uh,
we're having a benefit for him.
Eight o'clock at the laugh factory.
I'm going to be doing a bunch of
time trying on all this new stuff.
We're going to have a great time.
And um, he really was, you know,
92 to 99. He was just somebody I saw
like practically almost every day,
and we had so many great gigs before he
went into writing and all that type of
stuff. So it's an honor to do
something in his memory, um,
for a, for his is wonderful kids. Um,
and then we have to
Patrice O'Neal benefit.
Do you know yesterday was the five year
anniversary? Can you believe that? Wow.
I can't believe I haven't talked
to him in five years. That's crazy.
I'm been trashed by him.
Heard him laughing. Oh yeah.
And think of everything that happened.
I remember when,
when he speaking of sent Dusky right
after he died was when all of that shit
came out.
And I just remember
just trying to imagine what he would have
been talking about and I know that his
angle,
somehow he would've made,
he would have made that absolutely
hilarious. Um, but anyways, uh,
the next benefit is, um,
Tuesday, February 21st,
um, tickets has always have been
and been going along steadily.
They makes a great Christmas gift.
Ladies,
if you want to get something
for your husband, um,
it's going to be Leslie
Jones. Gary Gulman, Dan Soder,
Jim Norton, Rich Vos, Bobby Kelly, myself,
Keith Robinson.
I think I got everybody know he's trying
to have an eight or nine people. Um,
it's such a,
Oh, I'm so bummed I'm going to miss
that. I'm going to miss a Leslie Jones.
She's going to that I love to see here.
Do you stand up?
I'd better not be going on after.
Uh,
can I just say being in the Green
Room at tough crowd with Colin Quinn,
with Patrice,
like I dunno,
like two times a week is
probably the most like fun.
I lacked every single day on that job
and he was definitely him. Geraldo,
you know, we're such like a big
part of that. And like, I dunno,
it's just having Patrice around
saying the most offensive,
like a horrible, horrible things
that you can say as a man to a woman.
But they were always funny. Like I can't
deny the fact that like, I'd be like,
fuck you, but I would be so funny.
At the same time. It's like,
that's the infuriating thing
about comedians. It's like,
it's like you guys say the most
fucked up shit, but it's so funny.
So it's hard to stay mad at you. So
we're just fucking around. I know. No,
and it's all, it's all like whatever.
You shouldn't be laughing at this,
but it's so,
well,
you want to hear a classic come comedians
story real cause it David tell story.
Hmm.
So we're at fucking standup New York and
there was a little person in the room,
right?
I'm a little person in the comedy club.
I think I kind of just fucked the
whole thing up. Right. Was there.
So the fucking club owner was all like,
you know, okay, there's a, you know,
it's a little person is, you
know, at the show tonight,
let's not make any joke with Bob Bland,
so everybody's not doing jokes and stuff,
blah, blah, blah, blah. And he
says it's to Dave [inaudible].
Dave just goes, AH, okay.
Yeah. Right. And he walks right up on
stage in a me first thing in his mouth.
He just goes, I understand. We
have a little man in the room.
Yeah. Whole place labs.
The dude laughed. Sorry.
Sorry,
just went red line that he fucking laughed
any fucking set all of this shit and
the guy loved it and had a great
fucking time. Yeah. And I, I dunno man,
I was just one of those
things where I moved.
I was brand new when I saw him do that.
Like to meet up to just disobey an
order from a New York City club owner.
I was like, oh my God. And
he's still going to get spots.
If I went a minute over where I was
on the, on the ladder at that point,
if I went over like one fucking minute.
Um,
David tell at a bunch of those that
he did the gator growl one time,
which is he went down to the swamp,
which is like this fucking with
the gators play football and um,
you were supposed to work squeaky clean.
The uh,
Dean didn't want you to
fucking say anything dirty.
Brewer told me this story.
This is another one I'm going to
fuck up and cough my way through.
Said everybody works squeaky clean.
When he was sitting there wondering
how David Tell was going to handle it.
And Dave came out and just did the most
filthiest fucking joke from his act
right up front and then
looked right over at the,
at the whole board of the things
that he goes, fuck you Dane.
This one's for this students.
And the whole place went fucking nuts.
And then he murdered for like a half
hour and then I coughed myself to death.
All right. I gotta put some
clothes. Oh, Billy balled out.
Hopefully Paul said you cough, your
robe opens. It's a little bit more.
Well, you know what, Nia, you got to
tease the crowd a little. All right.
That's the podcast for Thursday.
Have a great weekend. Your comments.
Um,
and I'll talk to you on Monday there.
MMM.
Anyways, new Pope a Boston. Billy loved
the podcast. Keep up the good work.
Thank you. What do you make of all
this news about the pope retiring?
Oh Geez. Geez. Personally I'm not that
religious and don't really care that much.
Maybe if they elected a new pope that
was young. Well that was a young,
some young hot lady in her
twenties I would give a shit.
What do you think bill?
Is there more to the story than that?
They're not telling us where
his age and health issues.
The only reason he retired is the
church covering anything up. Um,
I'll come on do it. Are they covering
anything up? They fucking have been.
Certain percentage of them have
been covering up other fucking kids.
Okay.
For a long time, you know, during
World War Two there was a, you know,
they got in bed with the Nazis.
I mean,
it really is one of the worst organization
as far as some of the shit that
they've done,
you know,
but people are so wrapped into not pissing
off the invisible guy in wanting to
go to the happy place and get to eat
marshmallows for the rest of you fall
fucking eternity. That they are
actually, it's really, it's,
it's disturbing.
Okay.
That people can still be part of
that religion. You know what I mean?
I don't understand how, you know, the
stuff that they've done. So, uh, yeah,
I would say, yeah, there's probably
something going on. I don't know.
Maybe he said something
like, Hey, you know, ah,
maybe we should apologize for,
uh,
having that clam bake with Adolf Hitler.
She'll be a maybe clear the air
with that one. Hey, what do you say?
Oh,
we actually don't help to pay for the
lawyers of the people in our organization
who put their dicks in the acids of kids.
You know,
maybe he said something like that. I
have no idea. Anyways, he said also,
what are some, some of the ways that they
could make the church more interesting?
For example,
maybe let broads become priests.
I bet more people would pay attention.
Or how about letting people sit in lazy
boys instead of sitting and kneeling and
those terrible rock hard benches
they call pews. I know, it's so dumb.
The whole thing is to get you like
you're not worthy. You're not worthy.
You're not worthy. Get on your
fucking knees and it's in, it's all,
it's all made up by human
beings taking a guess and,
and other adults because they get into
it as kids. They, they, I don't know why.
I actually know why.
Cause I believe that there was like a
spirituality and I believe that you feel
good when you do good things.
And I just think that you can't corral
that nobody owns it and you can't put a
fucking like,
okay,
I think that all churches should just
be philosophies rather than this,
this hardened way of looking at things.
Um,
just the amount of death
that it has caused. I don't,
I'm not saying anything fucking know. You
guys know how I feel on this shit. Um,
finally, how about we live in up the
music a bit and add some newer sounds.
Maybe a little guitar and drums.
Well,
what you need to do is
go to a Baptist church,
go to a church where you don't see any
white people going in there. Um, that,
that would be a good one to start
with. And I bet you're amazing. You'll,
you'll hear people who are actually in
those churches probably sing bay better
than half the people who won
grammys that year. I mean,
how many times you've seen some emaciated
whore sticking her finger in a year.
Lao who trying to act like they
know how to sing and what do they,
what's behind them all the fucking time.
It's always like fucking three black
chicks or two black chicks to some black
dude. I mean, that's where the music
is. That's where it's coming from.
If that's what you want,
just fucking go there.
Okay.
They're not going to give a shit.
Right. They might look at you weird,
but after a while, once they see you
feel the music, you should be fine.
You should be fine. The
rest of the Shit, I dunno.
I think that they should
maybe update the stories
every once in a while.
Okay.
Maybe, uh, just make up some new shit.
Just say, Oh, you know what, God,
God came back again and the
burning Bush said, uh, you know,
let he who never a illegally
downloaded the song.
Just something to fucking update it.
I don't know what to tell you.
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
Updated, I guess. You know, there are
some sort of, some of those new age,
the new age ones are just to scary because
then somehow somebody always ends up
saying there, Jesus, and
the next thing you know,
you're surrounded by the FBI and
there's tank shooting flames at yet,
or you're waiting for some aliens to come.
And next thing you know,
everybody's drinking some
poison and you're dying of
fucking bunk bed, you know,
or in the middle of the jungle with some
sweaty fucking Conga player or whatever
the fucking that guy's name was.
Yeah.
You know,
I think you're is,
when it comes to us spirituality and
that type of shit, I think you're really,
you're better off on your own.
Um,
I think, you know, I think generally
speaking, if you're not a psycho,
you kind of know how to
be a decent human being.
I'm not saying that you're always
succeed in it. I certainly don't, but,
um,
I don't know how the fuck do I put it.
I would rather sit at a bar about six,
seven beers in and talk to somebody else
who is in the same mind frame and talk
about life than I would to actually go
to a church and listen to some guy up
there going, Eh, any did shop
day Gaddy did shop thing.
Aus, hey did it for
you. He died painfully.
I hope you appreciated.
Then I'll lay low yarrow way.
We are,
you're not fucking worthy.
We want you to remember this.
Your a of Shit.
You better hope he's not mad at you.
I lay Lou.
Yeah. Wow. Lailu yeah, I mean who the
fuck wants to sit there through that?
I mean there's still telling stories
about lepers. Can we fucking update it?
You know,
the world was flat.
Now the world is flat and there was some
lappers and a guy at a big boat stuck
some animals on,
what am I singing?
I don't even know.
I shouldn't have listened to my mother.
I caught you end up in that,
okay, here's a job where you,
you're not going to be able to
ever fuck another woman again,
you know?
Yeah. Well do I get a wife
now? You don't get that.
You're going to sit in his dorm room with
a bunch of other guys. None of you are.
Begin I going to get any pussy whatsoever.
Okay?
Okay. There you go. There's a natural
check. The whole thing is just like,
as far as the Catholic way,
it's just like just flogging yourself.
Do you understand how fucked up?
But you got one fucking life.
You should be out having the time of
your life, you know, not hurting anybody,
but having the time,
you life and enjoying it because you
fucking deserve it because you were lucky
enough to be born a human being
and not a fucking house fly.
What if reincarnation is true? All right?
And you're gonna fucking come back is,
is uh, uh, I don't know. Something a snaky
what? Those little fucking
lizards sitting at Darton around.
Even if you don't get eaten by a snake,
you only live like 14 days.
You can fucking drive a car,
you know,
gave you never see a
lizard doing that shit.
Good
sleep.
Scottish, Cardinal. Oh, Brian.
Cardinal O'brien apologizes for
my sexual conduct. You know,
I'm getting sick of people apologizing
for shit and they dance around.
Okay.
This guy basically to use my new word,
he buggered some kids.
All right?
He took out his holy Cock Oleo
and stuck it in their fucking uh,
uh, uh, what the fuck
was Jesus born in a shed?
What do they always call it?
Okay.
You know, at are always around
Christmas. I remember what it's called.
What was he boys born in a barn,
but they give it some biblical,
what's the name for a Biblical
Barn? I don't give a fuck. Anyways,
it says a Scottish cardinal who had
earlier earlier challenged allegations of
his sexual impropriety,
claims that once again claims at once
again shine an international spotlight and
the alleged alleged sexual abuse evolving
row involving Roman Catholic clergy
reverse course Sunday.
And the guy, I apologize,
this is how he apologizes for Bass.
I for as far as I can tell,
fucking children in the ass.
Yeah.
He said,
I wish to take this opportunity to
admit that there have been times that my
sexual conduct has fallen below the
standards expected of me as a priest.
Archbishop.
And cardinal
in recent days,
certain allegations which have been made
against me have become public initially.
There are anonymous and nonspecific
nature led me to contest them to those I
have offended.
I apologize and ask forgiveness to those.
I've offended.
You know,
I've been lucky enough in my life to
have never been unwantedly fucking banged
in the ass by a fucking priest.
But I don't,
I think I can be empathetic enough
and say that if this was happening,
at no point would I be turning
around going, you know,
that's what you're doing is
really offensive. I find this,
you know what the fuck.
When you apologize,
you should have to say
what the fuck you did.
And if you're going to talk like this,
there should be somebody obnoxiously
yelling off the mic like what you did like
during this should have been like,
I wish to take each opportunity to
admit that there have been times that my
sexual conduct has fallen below the
standards expected of me as a priest.
Yeah. And it's a fucking human being.
You're not supposed to fuck kids.
And regent days,
certain allegations fucking of children
which have been made against me have
become public Bob flock and tie.
Initially there are anonymous and
nonspecific nature led me to contest them.
How many different ways to play it?
You talk,
you're fucking dead to put in
their ass. You get the point. Um,
good lord to those.
I have offended to those you're raped.
You're a fucking rapist.
And like,
like how like he tries to tie
in the fact that he's a priest
like below the standards expected
of me as a priest, Archbishop,
archbishop and Cardinal.
Okay.
So like
what if you,
if you were a pope that was okay or
was it because you never became a pope?
So these guys basically been dental and
kids ever since he got into that fucking
hurt. How is that thing still
in business is just fucking do,
hey,
what's going on?
It's the Monday morning podcasts that
I'm actually doing this week on a Sunday
just because tomorrow, um, I
have to uh, have to be on set.
Yeah, look at me. Big Time.
Hollywood guy. Sorry people,
I don't have time for you
tomorrow. I have to be on set. Oh,
you like that for us.
I'm actually shooting.
I'm shooting something tomorrow, so I
got to do that tomorrow. There you go.
You like, you like how I worked at
in, you guys didn't even ask me.
I didn't have to tell you.
I'm one of those guys.
I arrogantly work my resume
into every sort of conversation.
You think it's going to rain tomorrow?
Well, you know, when I was taping,
I love the 80s. They were telling me
that tomorrow it's supposed to, you know,
people do that.
Then you want to fucking do something
violent or maybe, maybe not.
Maybe not.
Maybe people aren't like me.
It makes you realize what a
fucking angry asshole I am. Um,
on a whole nother level. This past
month, I just, uh, I'm just really,
uh,
difficult to be around and um,
that's it. Say, yeah, it's a fucking,
it's a pretty hardcore
moment to have with yourself.
Stay yourself in the mirror
and to be like, dude,
if I could somehow walk out of
this fucking situation, I would.
And I was supposed to be here with you.
So, um, anyways, I hope everybody had an,
uh, a nice, happy thanksgiving.
I hope you had a good time.
And, uh, I had a great one and
a I fucked up last week though.
I was, I was, I had done
basically like, you know,
seven attempts at this podcast and uh,
you know,
trying to make sure I was thanking
everybody and I totally fucked up on the
seventh take and I forgot to
thank uh, Michael Hanes, the uh,
the announcer for the Colorado avalanche.
A Guy I met on the road,
whoever dental, he likes my comedy and
found out I was a hockey fan. So the,
he the fuck it avalanche.
We're playing the kings hooked me up
with some tickets and interviewed me in
between periods,
you know,
like I was fucking Diane Cannon
at a Laker game. You know,
it's sort of a drop off
with celebrity when he got,
when you go to the La King game, you
know you go to La Laker game, you know,
who are you going to get? You know you
got Jack Nicholson fucking Willsmith,
all those guys.
Even if he go to a clippers game,
Billy crystal sits court side along with
that black dude from a different world
where that guy with the glasses,
the round John Lennon glasses.
But when you go to a kings game,
now that John Candy died,
actually when did he die? He died a
long time ago. But ever since he died,
the kicks, I like that.
That's like, it's classic La.
When Gretzky showed up then all and all
the fucking people came out, you know,
and then he leaves and John Candy dies.
That was sort of a combo,
you know, boom, boom. And
everyone's like, fucking, I'm
not going to go there. So now,
what am I trying to say here?
I'm trying to say that if they Yanka
celebrity out of the fucking stands at a
kings game,
you're going to get somebody at my level,
basically a non celebrity who hasn't had
the decency to at least become fat or
an an addict.
So you could enjoy me on a reality show.
I am a responsible,
semi noticeable human being
who pays his bills on time.
And if that isn't compelling, I don't
know what it is. Actually, you know some,
I went to La Kings game one time a long
time ago back at the La Forum and I saw,
uh, I saw, why am I
thinking Mike Adam Lee,
it's not Mike anime.
That was the host of NFL
81 with Bryant Gumbel.
I'm totally going.
Who's the fucking guy who did a he?
Jesus Christ. He was the announcer
when, ah, the miracle on ice.
Uh, Michael Al Michaels, Jesus Christ,
they go al Michaels was there,
big fan of hockey.
I saw him and I really wanted to
say something to him, but he had,
I could see the wrinkles in his
forehead that he was like, I know,
I know you like me, but please I'm here
with my kid. And I was like, all right.
And we set it all with the wrinkles in
our foreheads. Pretty amazing moment.
You know, I've always had that kind
of connection with people to be know,
like communicate through the
third eye. Um, all right.
If you knew to my podcasts
where the fucking event,
I've been doing them for
over a year, you know? No,
now what you jumping on the bandwagon
because I'm finally over 20 listeners,
you know,
because I actually got a compliment today
from somebody in a jolly old England.
I got something in England. Listen
to this shit. He liked that.
I'm on two different continents,
so it's not numbers,
it's not the amount of people you
have listening to your podcast.
It's the amount of, of uh, of
countries. All right, look at me.
I'm going global just like everybody else,
just like everybody else.
So, uh, so anyways, um,
could I really do the podcast and I'll
talk about the guy who got trampled at
Walmart.
I mean,
if it's just fucking unbelievable,
I just don't, I, you know,
how bad is the fucking economy that,
you know,
some guy opening the door to a
fucking store that sells garbage cans,
shack it's,
and fucking rakes gets trampled to death.
What the fuck were those people
running for? I Dunno. I like,
are they trying to say people broke down
the door? I really don't think they did.
I think that they were being pressed
up against it. If you're first in line,
why are you going to break down the
door? You know, think about that analogy.
You want to be extra first.
That doesn't make any sense.
And people were pushing from behind.
They basically created a,
they had general seating
like the who in Cincinnati.
He can't fucking do that shit.
And for years, right? Every,
every year at Christmas,
you see the doors,
they burst open.
There's always a big black girl loses
her fucking wig when she falls on the
ground.
And it always a dirty white dude with
the wranglers and one of his pant legs
gets ripped off as he tries to come
in through the, the overnight mailbox.
You know, it was inevitable.
It was fucking inevitable.
What of God damn way to go.
That's I absolutely fucking tragic.
And I don't even know why I brought
it up. I just, I can't get over it.
I can't get over that.
Somebody died doing that.
You know
how you supposed to die at Walmart?
You know, I dunno. Maybe
you stocking the shelves.
He just come fucking slamming
down on that linoleum floor.
Even then coma benefit,
you know,
you get to meet the local sports hero.
You know,
you're out on long island.
Bill Guerin comes in and signs of fucking
island, his jersey, his just
fucking, and you know, you know,
you're not supposed to die a
Walmart. That's just, that's
like a really, I dunno.
What do you guys think about that?
Do you think Walmart is at fault there?
Keep me for years. You know, I don't,
I don't know who's at fault there.
I mean Walmart, you know,
they come into the town,
they basically fucking fuck over
every small business there. Now,
I bet all those people
with small business owners,
they don't have any fucking money now.
So now they're pressed up against the
glass. Oh my God, I need to get a rake.
It's fucking nine. Open the doors. I mean,
they literally created that fucking thing.
Jesus Christ went,
why don't I read before I do these?
I really build.
And they literally created what in your
head. You fucking moron. All right,
let's get to the podcast questions. Like
I said, if you're new to my podcast,
people send me questions. Uh,
they send me comments. They, uh,
they tried to educate me on
certain things and I them,
but it doesn't happen so much
that way because I'm a moron.
So let's get to the first question
of the week. Question number one.
Boy Did I even think Michael
has. Yeah. So Michael,
thank you very much for putting me on
in between periods, man. That was a, uh,
it was unbelievable. And,
uh, they actually let me,
had given Peter McNabb let me hang out
as the game started and I really realized
how hard it is to tell stories
as you're watching the game.
Like I couldn't even focus and
I actually talked over a goal.
I was elite in the middle of telling a
story during a breakaway and I didn't
even,
I'm so into trying to be funny on TV.
I didn't notice that it was like a fucking
two on one and then the guy scored.
So I had to cut my story short by
saying, oops. I was like, yeah.
Then my dad was crazy. Oops.
That's what I literally said. Oops.
On national television at that point
I wanted to crawl out the studio,
but it was still awesome.
Anyways. All right, here we go.
Podcast questions of the week.
Question number one, Bill,
have you ever been confronted by midgets
about your bit midgets or done it in
front of midgets? Um,
actually, uh, I had a, uh,
I had a small person,
whatever you supposed to call them,
send me an email.
And the bit was basically,
I don't understand why the word
midget is offensive, you know,
it's not like Mitch, it's foot dragged
here from another country, you know,
packed into a boat,
you know,
the whole Amistad thing and then
fucking forced to uh, you know,
have them in 38 of their friends crawl
out of a car in the middle of a circus.
You know, I did jokes like that, you
know, I don't understand. You know,
it's just a word that's a table.
That's the lamp and you're a midget.
That's how the joke went. Plus Niche. It
sounds tough. Fucking midget, you know.
But then this guy actually a little
person actually wrote me and said,
actually midget is offensive because
it came, I get somebody on Barnum,
Bailey came up with it and it, it's
actually a form of the word and Mitch,
which I guess is some sort of little bug.
So it somehow came out of that.
So you basically say, Mitch,
you just saying that
they're just a little,
little bug that you could just step on.
I'm going to be tier one of their legs
off and watch them run around in a circle.
So yeah, it is offensive. So
I have been confronted, um,
you know, some left last night, somebody
did a joke about a dwarf and there was a,
I think a little person in the
crowd and, uh, I looked over at him,
so their face, you know,
sorta crinkle up a little bit.
Like even on a holiday weekend,
I have to deal with this and
I felt a little bad for him.
I try not to look at the crowd
when I talk because uh, you know,
I got a lot of shit that could bug
people. Can I answer that? Okay.
Question number two, Bill. I
want to be a standup comedian.
Do you want to be a standup comedian?
Sure. We all do. We hear it. The Vri.
Um, okay. Dave said on insight,
I'm assuming this is Chappelle
sent on inside the actor's studio,
that if you want to be a standup comedian,
you have to take acting lessons.
Did you take acting
lessons? Uh, yes, I have.
Although you would never know it if you
ever saw me act. Thank you. Um, yeah,
I've taken acting lessons and uh,
I haven't taken them in a while, but, um,
I dunno why. I Dunno why I stopped taking
acting lessons. Why did I, you know, why?
Cause I hated the classes.
They were too fucking long
and then I was always, um,
I dunno, I would, it was always
like that one person who, who, uh,
who sucks so bad that it made
me want to quit the class.
You know, we used to call them bathroom,
bathroom break guy. Like, you know,
like when they went up to do this scene,
you went to go take a bathroom break.
But I would tell you this, if you
want to become a comedian, I mean,
I don't know if acting
helps you stand up or not,
but I know it definitely helps you
when you get to the next level of this
business when you have to shoot
something like I do tomorrow,
that a, if you've taken acting
lessons that you had, you know,
you actually know how to do it. So, um,
I mean if you wanted to be a comedian,
just write five minutes
of shit you think's funny.
Sign up for an open mic when they call
your name, go up there. Um, you know,
you'll be fine. You don't have
to recite Shakespeare, but, um,
as you get going along,
I would definitely take acting classes,
improv classes for as much
as comedians make fun of it.
Improv class has really helped
you. Uh, I think enacting,
because you're literally
improving with other,
another person in stand up is so solitary.
You're just standing on
stage in and with the crowd,
but it's still all you and you don't
really have to wait for someone else.
I could go on forever about
this shit. So yeah, right.
Five minutes of Shit you
think's funny and um,
sign up for an open mic and then, you
know, once you get that thing going, take,
take anything.
Sketch a sketch class as
many things as you can learn.
I would, you know, I mean,
the amount of times I kicked myself
for not learning how to tap dance.
I mean I just can't tell. No, Kim.
I was just thinking back to the Vaudeville
days when you had to be a triple
threat. Funny. Be able to dance and
sing before it became, you know,
it's like the NFL. You just,
I just play on special teams.
You know I'm the long snapper.
You ever feel like football teams back
in the 20s they had like eight guys on
him. All right. Question number
three. All right, Bill. Tonight,
me and my friends were having an art.
We're having an argument about ac DC.
He was saying how Angus young is hands
down the coolest motherfucking guitar
player of all time.
While I agree with that,
I just think it's time for him to
lose the schoolboy outfit. I mean,
isn't a dude like approaching
60 believe it or not,
Angus is only 53 years old.
He made it when he was like 19 or 20 he
was born in 1955 Malcolm young was born
in 1953 and bond Scott I believe,
was born in 1946 okay.
I just established that I'm a geek.
Now let's get back to ACDC. You
know what, I got to agree with you.
I think a actually read an article
recently where he was talking about,
Angus was talking about having to put
on that schoolboy outfit and he said,
and quote unquote, I have
to become that guy. But um,
I dunno, that's a very like I
would totally, I don't know.
What would it look like if Angus
actually puts some jeans on and started
bouncing around the stage like that?
It would definitely take a minute.
But you're really fucking with,
uh,
the whole formula and ACDC
formula has never wavered.
They're like,
we're singing about balls,
the devil and Pussy and drinking and
they have not veered away from that for
over 33 years.
So I mean,
I don't know if you put pants on,
is the whole house of cards come down?
I think it would take a minute,
but I wouldn't have a problem.
I wouldn't have a
problem you put pants on.
I really would not have a problem with it.
Um,
you know what they should do?
They should do an ACDC unplugged
where they still play electric.
But Angus gets to sit down and around
with all the other band members kind of
like on Elvis has come back special where
it was still like electric. Well, so,
ah, Mama, remember that one?
All right. Um, all right,
question number four. So not even answer
that, do I think it's time to like,
I wouldn't bother me,
but I can definitely see why he
continues to wear that outfit because a,
I wouldn't want to fuck with that formula.
So podcast question number four.
Hey Bill, I signed up
for your email list. Uh,
thanks for the confirmation email.
Very corporate like, yeah, fuck you.
Like I got a guy running my website a
little bit. What do you want from me?
You know, we, we basically have, you
know, my email list on my website.
Basically what happens is
people who have an AOL email,
if two of them mark you as spam,
you get kicked off the Internet.
So I'm trying to get rid of all the,
all people who don't want me.
That's why I sent that out. Okay.
And that's why we confirmed it. Okay.
Anyways, he says, I'm 19 and
I haven't sex since 2006.
Jesus Christ. Where's this
going? When I was 16 years old,
well first of all,
I'm not sympathetic because I didn't
lose my virginity until I was fucking 19.
Um, I dunno what the Hell's going on. Uh,
and I wanted to know how long your longest
dry streak was and how you ended it.
Well, I just ruined the joke the first 19
years of my life. Uh, how did I end it?
I met some chick who sang in a band who
was fucking about 37 years old and I
think you can fill in
the blanks. Um, okay.
Well I don't want you saying once,
once I was in the game,
what's the longest I went?
Uh,
I think the first fucking year and a half,
maybe two years of my comedy career.
I swear to God, I was finishing college.
I was living at home with my parents and
I was doing standup at night. I mean,
I barely had time to rub one out.
Not to mention, I had like, you know,
people say I had,
I have no game with women.
If you know in technically there's
no way to be lower than ground zero.
Somehow I was, I was below,
I was below ground zero.
Have no game with women to the point like,
do you ever hear the end of whole lot of
love when Robert Plant's sings the echo
of what he's about ready to sing comes
first to indicate that he's in hell.
That's like when I would hit on girls,
the echo of the awful line that I was
going to say to them that that would come
out first.
And then my awful said they were already
walking away before I opened my mouth.
So probably about two years. So what
are you on your about two years? Yeah,
but dude, you know some, I know
another comic he got laid at like 14.
He didn't get laid again
until he was like 18. Um,
don't worry about it. You know, how
can you get out of it? It's just,
it's a numbers game. Just, you know
what, rub one out before you go out.
So that takes the pressure off.
Now you don't give a shit and then just
go out there and start saying the shit
that your brain is telling you.
Not to say like,
don't say that that will offender.
That's the kind of shit you
need to start saying. I mean,
I don't mean walk up to
her and just be like, Hey,
what's up?
You fucking can't.
I'm not saying say that. I'm just
saying that. You know what I mean?
I can't even think of a fucking example.
Just, I dunno. He just, you know,
and you start steering the conversation
towards sex and when she acts like she's
offended, just tell her that she's
not offended. You know? You know,
you just do that shit.
You just keep it.
It's one of those things
you just have to learn.
You have to learn what your
style of being an asshole is.
This is if you're going
to try to get laid,
if you want to meet the woman of your
dreams, don't do that. Then you have to,
I guess listen to your heart. And I have
no idea why. It just made me feel creepy.
Um, which is probably why
not married. Okay. Um, all
right, let's move along. Okay.
Question number five. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you.
In large capital letters, they're
like, I forgot the word capital,
so I had to say large so I could buy
time in my brain to come up with capital
capital's okay. Um, I'm so tired of
people trashing conspiracy theory.
All this was last week.
Why defendant can sips conspiracy theory.
I'm so tired of people trashing
conspiracy theory without looking into it.
I'm not saying that all
of the theories are valid,
but I also think people have a tendency
to be, to be questionless sheep.
I just want to say thank you for telling
those fucks to think for themselves a
bit. Um, yeah, I mean, I
wasn't going in that hardcore.
Yeah. But I definitely think,
yeah, people just, yeah, if it's on
TV, it's true. If it's on the Internet,
then if that's the Internet's were all
the lies are, that's kind of like racism.
Like all the racist white
people are just in the south,
but everybody in Connecticut is cool.
You know, those, that type of mindset.
Anyways, here's this question. Why aren't
you coming to Chicago anytime soon?
Make it happen is all I'm
saying. Jesus Christ. All right.
I'm very demanding.
Um,
while I was there in March when me and
I don't know where the hell you are,
there's a lot of cities out there.
I try to come through about once a year.
Chicago is definitely on my, uh, I
felt like a politician right now. Yeah,
we're definitely looking into that and uh,
it's definitely on the agenda
and when the time is right,
we're going to handle the situation
in Chicago Nets. Next question please.
All right Phil, how many emails do you
get with the word dude in the subject?
Probably a shit ton. Here's another
one. Deal with it. You know,
so I think people are starting to feed
off my attitude where you guys are being
assholes to me for no reason.
Kind of like how I'm assholes to people.
The West me questions for
no reason. All right, Bill.
I was making my breakfast
and my 900 square foot,
$450,000 condo this morning,
attempting to determine what,
which optane of gasoline I was
going to use to burn down my bank.
Okay. And then finally,
this bailout ass raping,
uh, really clicked. I mean,
I knew we were getting bent over
the table on this whole deal,
but not in such an obvious manner. Our
government is taking our money via taxes,
getting it to bank so they can loan us
our own money back and interest that
fucking taking our money so they can
loan it back to us for more money.
And the cop mitigating ass
clowns in Washington are
all voting yes on this shit.
How the fuck did this happen?
Um,
I mean, I don't know,
I'm not in the Senate,
but I would imagine that
if you print the money,
you have enough money
to pay off politicians.
So they basically do whatever the
banks want them to do. I mean, I dunno,
it's,
it's brutal.
I'm trying to get out from underneath
the house of Rothschild trying to get out
from underneath the red shield.
That's what I'm doing. Um,
yeah. I don't know what to
tell you do. How do they do it?
Because they're the guys run and
shit. And uh, if you can just print,
what would you do if you
could print money, you know,
and everybody accepted the money
that you are printing. I mean I
could you handle that level of
power. I I couldn't, you know,
and what if your job depending on,
you know,
dependent on doing what
those guys wanted you to do.
I mean they were right above you.
I guess you would do it right.
I have no idea. You know
what's fascinating? That's
like I said, like those,
that's like one of those will Smith
summer blockbuster movie kind of plots.
I don't know why they're voting yes on it.
I think some are voting yes on it because
they want to keep their positions.
I don't think other people are voting
yes on it cause they don't really
understand it. Kind of like
make like you just think, well,
if we own the old billion dollars,
why don't they just print $1 billion?
Just pay it off.
And the reason is because
I guess you still owe the money to
the bank because the Federal Reserve
Princeton and you've got to pay
interest on the billion dollars.
So you'd never get out of debt.
I Dunno,
I can't even fucking explain it anymore.
Probably sound like a moron, which I am.
I've been really meaning to read that
book the case against the Federal Reserve.
I really have been. All right.
Question number seven. Hey,
just wondering if you have a version
of the aristocrats joke and what you
thought of that documentary Jillette
made of it. Um, I don't think Penn,
I don't think Penn Jillette
made that documentary. I was a,
I'm like, God, I just went blank on his
name. It's another comedian who made that.
Maybe I can Google it, um, on,
anyways,
it's like Google this.
I am DB it Paul Paul
Provenza, he's a guy. Made it.
Paul Provenza directed that. Um, anyways,
let me get back to the questions
here. Was, I have an incoming call.
I gotta wrap this podcast up here.
All right. What did I think about a,
do I have a version? Do I have a version
of the aristocrats jokes? No, I don't.
And I never heard of that
joke until I saw the, uh,
the documentary on it.
I bet in a lot of green rooms and in
16 years coming up on 17 years of doing
stand up, I've never, I never
even heard the joke. So,
uh,
but I thought I liked the movie.
I thought it was funny and Bob Saget was
my favorite because he seemed to be the
guy,
like he was improving so much that he was
making himself laugh at all the filthy
shift that he was coming
up with. Um, and yeah,
if you haven't seen it, I would definitely
run it cause I think it's a funny,
funny documentary. There you go. And
it's Paul Provenza not pendula. Alright.
And I don't even look that up, but I,
I'm pretty sure that's true. All right.
Question.
Are you drinking again so that I can buy
you a bear when you come to Tampa? Yes,
I am. I am drinking again. Um,
that's the name of my neck. Stand up.
Special Bill Berg drinking again.
I'm going to come on stage,
completely shit faced and
just fucking berate people.
I'm glad to see that you're
finally coming by the way.
And what better time than January.
Well, what happens in Tampa in January?
I guess I'm getting out of the winter.
Um, all right. Overrated. Underrated.
Before I wrap up this podcast,
overrate it, Barack Obama. Seriously,
the guy was senator for two years
and he hasn't even taken office yet.
And people think he's the second coming.
I'm not hating on the man,
but I'm not ready to worship him yet.
Um,
well I think a lot of it has
to do with, uh, you know,
just the last eight years
have been a little rough
without getting too political,
you know,
I mean,
George Bush literally should have been
doing speeches with a flashlight under
his chin.
He was so busy scaring the shit out of
people for the last eight fucking years.
I think it's just going to be a
relief to have somebody come in. Uh,
you know, Jesus Christ, just somebody
different, somebody different.
But yeah, I mean of the elders, you
know, just feel good thing. Yeah.
We elected a black guy.
That means we're not as ugly
a country as we were before.
You know, I don't know. I
think everybody's life is
in the shitter and that,
just hoping that somebody
can do something. But I
definitely agree with you.
If you're waiting for one guy to take
that office and to turn your life around
you, uh, you know, it's kind of
like when I get in this business,
you get a manager and an
agent, you're like, well,
I guess I don't need to do any more work.
They just going to bring shit to me.
It doesn't work that way. All
right. Underrated. Playoff hockey.
Every round is so fucking intense.
And the fact that they play a seven game
series makes the drama in the bad blood
continue for one game to the next.
Uh,
I would definitely say that I think
the NHL package is a underrated.
I have that. Here's the last one and
then I'm wrapping this up for this week.
Um, overrated. I love this
one. This is such a great one.
Overrated first impressions.
Uh,
my first impressions are wrong.
Most of the time,
society needs to drop the significance
of first impression. There go,
there goes me generalizing. Maybe.
Um, I just have horrible judgment.
Now you don't, I think that's great. Yeah.
My first impressions are mostly wrong
and people's first impressions of me,
a lot of times the wrong,
um,
I think they are my girlfriend staring
at me right now. Like bullshit. You know,
I fuck you. It's true. This is the
deal. You know what? This is what,
this is what I found.
If you're a quiet person and you meet an,
an a, uh, an insecure person,
they misinterpret your quietness for
arrogance and they start thinking,
this guy thinks he's fucking better than
me. Then they think you're a Douche bag.
That's what people used to think of me
before I became a loud mouth asshole and
removed all doubt that I am an
arrogant cunt. But a lot of shy,
a lot of people considered arrogant
are, are not arrogant. They're fucking,
you know,
that doing what I'm doing,
they're being quiet because
they're questioning everything
they did in the last
17 minutes.
I don't know if that makes sense,
but I definitely think that's
true because I, you know,
there's a number of people I thought
were dicks when I first met him and it
turned out that I was the Dick.
And then there's been other
people I've been like, you know,
this guy's a cool fucking guy.
He's a real cool guy.
And then they turn out to be a
complete psycho. So, uh, I dunno,
I don't know what to tell you what,
that,
that's like that thing where he went
for every saying there's another saying
that can fucking cancel it out.
Penny saved is a penny earned.
You've got to spend money to make money,
walk softly,
carry a big stick greasy wheel.
The squeaky wheel gets the grease.
You know what I mean? Does that even
make sense? I don't fucking know.
Cause, yeah, your first impressions,
you know, your mind might be wrong,
but then you gotta go with your gut,
you know,
that got that says,
uh,
I shouldn't turn this trek because I
think this person's going to snap my neck.
You know,
it's the prostitute that listens to that.
They're the ones they get to continue
living the dream of sucking cock until
they're 55,
you know,
and finally having enough money to get
out from underneath their pimp to go to
night school. Those are the ones
because they listen to that gut.
But I got to admit, yeah, I would
have to go with you on the first, uh,
that I mentioned.
I bought a Credenza and you believe
that most adult thing I ever did,
I like looking at him pretending like I
have some sort of official business to
do. Um, okay. That's it.
And uh, other than that,
um,
well I got,
I got Carolyn Carolyn's coming up this
week. I got a brand new hour for you.
So all you bastards who are
still full of Turkey, um,
hit the fucking treadmill and come
down to the club. I got a brand new,
our shit that I'm really proud of and I'm
putting it together and hopefully I'll
be taping another special next year so
I can get on this doing a special every
two,
two and a half years.
So why can have some sort of body
of work at the end of this shit?
But I will not take any
special before its time.
What, what fucking, what,
what a, what? Advertise.
And we will serve no wine
before it's time. No,
fuck was that, I can't
remember. Anyways, that's it.
Everybody have a good week. And,
uh,
keep the podcast questions coming.
And people keep asking me if I'm going
to be on Facebook. Um, I like my space.
You know what I mean? I, you know, I like,
I gotta be loyal somewhere in my life.
I'm sticking it out with these
fucking guys. And, uh, you know,
I'm going to go through a couple
of rough years with my space when,
when we look in, like, I'm
still wearing bell bottoms,
but eventually it's going
to come back in style again.
And you guys can all be like, oh yeah
man, I'm fucking back on my space again.
And I'd be like, Oh yeah man.
Well I never fucking left.
So that means I'm cooler than you and
that'll make me feel good for six minutes
before it become miserable again.
All right everybody,
thank you so much for listening to the
podcast. I hope you all have a great week.
Thanks again to Michael Hanes for
letting me sit in on the ass game. Sorry,
I didn't think last week I fucking
space cause I'm a moron. And uh,
how about those broken?
Any hockey fans out there
hiding Canadian out there?
How can we not talking to any shit?
You like those two watts as you took it,
the hands of the points this month.
And Are you singing jackasses?
Goddammit. The fucking, you
gotta respect the Canadian.
So I saw him the other night coming
back against the buffalo Sabres.
So sons of bitches, those fucking people
start singing. It's like gladiator.
And all of a sudden though,
does,
if they start skating faster and then
you just know they're going to score that
goal to fucking tie it up every God damn
time. It's like watching Derek Jeter,
guy on his tie and runs on second, you
know he's going to slap, it's a right.
He's going to go the other way with it.
He's going to hit a double,
you know he's actually going to do okay
for all you fucking American League
pitchers. He's going to look
for fast ball. The first
pitch, that's what he does,
and he tries to pull it every
fucking time. In that situation,
that's what he looks for.
Okay?
But then if you give it to them
out over the plate, he'll kill.
Take what he gives you and then he
slaps it to right field. All right,
so why don't you throw a high fucking
inside fastball that the bottom drops out
of and at least get strike one on
the fuck. Can you please do that?
Okay. Sorry. It's got a little
upset there. I actually,
you know, next time I go,
I know when I'm in New York,
if you're a Yankee fan and he'd
come out to my Caroline show, uh,
if you want to see my impression of
Derek Jeter at taking a strike right down
the center of the plate, if you
want me to do that impression, um,
just yell out there in the show. I'm
actually encouraging people to heckle me.
What am I doing? Or
whatever. After the show,
I'll give you my
impression of Derek Jeter.
Add Bat standing there that does not
move off the shoulder and it's a strike
right down the center of the plate.
Without a fucking doubt, it is a strike.
A goddamn moron could call it a strike.
I will do my impression of
his body language taking
strike right down the plate.
How many different times you're going
to explain it. All right, I'm done.
Have a great day.
So
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].